this year marks 20 years since the first
harry potter movie
will the cast be getting together to
celebrate it all what plans do you guys
have
i don't know i'm sure there will be some
sort of uh celebration
i don't know if you've seen it but
especially in the pandemic a lot of
people went back to like watching the
movies
and there are literally tick tock
accounts devoted to reenacting the
scenes
especially yes people reenact the chess
scene between you and ron and hermione
constantly that seems like a really hard
one to reenact
guys you've gotten to play a lot of
really fun characters
for this show what was it like to don
these
period costumes and getting a covered
wagon how did this storyline feel
uh yeah it was fanta i loved um you know
i i love like period clothes and i also
basically just had one costume for most
of this season which is
great um and yeah i any time you get to
like
i mean play around in a historical
period i i think is like incredibly fun
and this is such a
both like dark uh and
crazy time in american history that it
felt like a very fertile
ground for comedy yeah it's um
the wardrobe process for me is always
interesting because sometimes that's
where i
can find the character and uh
and that was true on this and like dan i
basically had
one outfit you know maybe there were
some subtle changes along the way
yeah and steve i'll go to you for this i
mean i grew up learning about oregon
trail and and the computer game was very
big
did you recall this from your school
years and daniel i don't know if you
ever learned about it in school probably
not
wait a minute you should be asking
daniel this because he didn't play the
oregon trail
i was totally unaware of video games
in the 90s um yeah
so uh i didn't even i mean i heard you
guys
you know dan and and a few of our cast
members like
talking about the video game and i had
no idea what they were talking about
so daniel you did play it yeah so i was
i was sent to some like
typing course when i was all computer
course when i was like
eight or nine and after like hours of
doing
like trying to pretend i knew what ms
dos was they they would let you play
like 20 minutes of oregon trail
and so yeah it was the highlight of
every day um and it was it was great i
was very very bad at it as i feel like
you know giving children a game about
like long-term planning
is not really uh it does it's not gonna
go well but um
yeah it was very very fun well like you
said i mean
it's a grim time but you guys certainly
have fun with it uh
steve what was it like for you to get to
play an outlaw on this one i just love
watching you because it feels like
you're just delighting in like
i don't know and even some of the i mean
it's fart jokes but had me laughing i
love it i just love being able to escape
and laugh
i you know yeah what's what was fun
about playing benny the teen is that i
think he
really enjoys being an outlaw you know
um yeah he gets frustrated when he's not
recognized or
if people you know sort of joke about
him being too old to still be called
benny the teen
uh but that's you know that was
you know that that all just adds to the
fun of having you know all this richness
in the character
to play with and then getting to be with
our cast now this is the third
season and we really feel like a company
like like this
ensemble and um the fact that we get to
play different roles each
season and in different setting and this
year
western yeah it was pretty exciting
and daniel you're a reverend you really
you you really played him straight and
committed you know
he's he's gotta he wants to do good yeah
i mean that's the thing i feel like you
you have to start from that place
particularly because like
by the time you get to the end of the
season he has fallen
so far in terms of the oregon trail
takes a toll
on uh the it really is a test of faith
and of his uh kind of
rigid morality but yeah certainly in the
first episode he's somebody that is just
very very earnestly trying to help the
people around him even though
no one wants to listen to him
now daniel i gotta ask you about uh
another one of your
your very good guy roles this year marks
20 years
since the first harry potter movie will
the cast
be getting together to celebrate it all
what plans do you guys have
um no no yeah i have no plans at the
moment i'm like
um i'm uh i'm out i'm in the dominican
republic at the moment filming
um and then i'm gonna be like busy kind
of working on bits and pieces until the
end of the year so yeah i don't know i'm
sure there will be
some sort of uh celebration but i don't
know if we'll all be
um getting together or anything um yeah
i'm sorry if that is a disappointment to
anyone
no it's not well i wanted to ask you i
don't know if you've seen it but
especially in the pandemic a lot of
people went back to like watching the
movies and
there are literally tick tock accounts
devoted to re-enacting the scenes
especially yes people reenact the chess
theme between you and ron and hermione
constantly that seems like a really hard
one to reenact
that's like one of the craziest sets we
had that's great okay i will i will try
and see some of them then that's good
is there one scene that's your favorite
and or one scene you would go back and
redo if you could
um one thing i would go back and redo
they got me
they let me do the coolest stunt i've
ever been able to do was a
a 40 foot full down a roof
um i would i was on a wire but it was i
was like probably in free fall it was
only there to catch me at the end
um and i was absolutely terrified but
they
they were like i worked a lot with the
stunt department by then they were like
you can do this
do you want to try it and i said yes
then got up there and was absolutely
terrified
but um that was one of the things that
we did it like two or three times but
it was for the fourth film and i will
never be allowed to do a stunt like that
again
like i've i've realized since that that
was very special circumstances in this
on that set and i i will never be
allowed to do something like that again
so yeah something like that that would
be cool
do you have an all-time favorite scene
and i have you watched the movies at all
since they first came out
um not since they first came out i've
seen like bits uh
on tv for seconds before i go like oh or
if it's a scene someone else is in i'll
be like oh cool
but yeah i mean i i have really really
fond memories of all of my scenes with
like
um gary oldman and david thulis they
were the some of the
first scenes on like the third and then
the fifth film where i like started to
feel like
a young man who was like trying to
figure out what acting was and they were
yeah you know they were pretty cool
people to be around
pretty incredible uh steve i think the
only thing that might have made those
movies better would have been adding you
to them
i don't know if you've seen them but is
there a part you would have liked to
play oh now you're putting me on the
spot
i can i can i can cast it i feel like
i feel like you would have been a pretty
good serious also you're you're
unfortunately you are you are
you are too young for dumbledore but one
day could have that quality of that sort
of
kind warmth and all of that i don't know
i think there's many roles for stephen
foster
all right i'll let you guys go but real
quick uh if you were just gonna tell
people why to watch this new season of
miracle workers what they're gonna get
out of it can i get
one tease from each of you steve
um oh god i'm terrible at this stuff
look this is our third season um
if you've been watching the series you
know
we were in heaven we were in the dark
ages now we are
on the oregon trail and i think each
season keeps getting better
um i certainly loved it and uh give it a
try
yeah i should probably mention that
there is a dance scene in one of the
episodes that
is um absolutely top five one of the
most insane things i have ever filmed
um so yeah tune in for that as well
that's saying a lot from you all right
thank you both so much appreciate you
thank you
you